[Applause]
at this moment
Fernando patron is preparing to become
famous for a day I wanted to see what
it's like to be famous I think people
want to experience this because it's
like acceptance at its best
Fernando is being transformed into Nando
a new music sensation and his publicist
aria has arranged for three appearances
to help promote his upcoming album you
are going live on the radio in about 15
minutes
wait this is happening yeah you're going
to do get on the radio right now I'm
gonna [ __ ] have to wing this I've
never done anything like this they have
so many microphones in holy [ __ ] to
ensure that he takes his duties
seriously
Aria informs Fernando that the radio
hosts believe that he's an actual
celebrity aria
however radio hosts Tony sweet and
captain Ron have actually been secretly
given scandalous information to maximize
the publicity from disappearance so you
can feel free just to grill them as hard
as you want cuffs are cuffs are off
quality talk shows it's time to spread
the word so I'm sitting there and then
they start asking questions and they
start off pretty like tame they're like
asking me about my music and then they
pull out a tweet I saw online that you
you have things quotes such as I'm
excited to be a ho this weekend I don't
know if that's the right message for
your listeners I was like what the [ __ ]
like they're going through my [ __ ]
you see that that photo that we have I
think we can put it on the screen here
Tony when others the biggest areola was
a purple nurple action that I that I've
found online
what is this hole explain this one to me
is that a nipple they were taken out of
context
they were completely taken out of
context I understand what celebrities go
through when they're like that's not
what I meant because when I said I
wanted to go be a help that meant I
wanted to go have a good time
how do you explain it to the parents of
your fans that take you to these shows
how do you how do you judge how you
behave I would say to the parents of
their kids is like if you have a solid
foundation at home what I do won't ruin
your kid I got a interview great he
didn't there's only a couple questions
where he hesitated whether or not he
just started spitting out like he knew
the answer and then I got in character
when they started dragging me I was like
well [ __ ] it I'm gonna be character too
then it seems like it didn't take long
for that money to go to your head right
did you have this attitude before you
came into such well I've always been a
dick that was my first and last
interview ever I think from here on
everything will be via email
next Fernando is informed that he must
use his platform as a celebrity by
shooting an ad campaign to promote an
important charity so celebrities usually
have a cause that's very near to their
heart something that they care for so
they're like you have one too and I'm
like okay great you know coming from my
tweets about being a ho at the radio
station that was ready to uplift my
character and be the celebrity that
people want me to be so I get there they
have this very serious photo shoot so
I'm like oh this is gonna be something
tie and we're just gonna go for a very
nice black-and-white portrait of you
it's gonna be I don't know cancer
awareness HIV immigration something that
matters but then they [ __ ] tell me
I'm doing a commercial for the Orcas and
not just the Orcas because that kind of
makes sense
is funding Orca education or cut
education to educate them or us on the
orcas to do what this is not to educate
people about the orcas this is for the
orcas to get a better education now it's
like are you [ __ ] kidding me
hold on sorry they made me really post
like a knight usually smiling photos and
they were like no I'll give me like a
little once more
[Music]
and you're the face of Oregon education
yes I am so we finish the photo shoot
and then have to film a commercial hey
guys it's me Nanda multimillion wait hey
guys it's me Nando multimillion album
[ __ ] what doesn't work you just have to
cut around those hey guys it's me Nando
every year many orcas die the orcas due
to a lack of access to education have
been living a lifestyle that is not
sustainable for them or for us the orcas
Nia's we need to fund their education in
the ocean here and across the world if
we do this for them today
they'll return the favor tomorrow the
orcas my name is Nando and I support the
orca education fund initiative well that
was certainly a powerful message so the
first was done and I'm like alright that
today was fun you know like I went to
the radio and I did a an interview and
then I did a photo shoot in a commercial
I was a celebrity for a day I'm good to
go and then I was like oh we have a
meet-and-greet with your fans and like
what fence
[Applause]
this is ridiculous to complete the
experience Aria has brought in a host of
talented actors from the American
immersion theater props to this group of
actors they made me believe that they
were my fans and I have no friends I
barely have friends so then they tell me
you have to walk down Hollywood
Boulevard and then you could have a meet
and greet around there knows I go get
fine so we start walking and I start
hearing people say my name I realized
that the actors were spread through the
street to follow me as if I was a real
celebrity so that other people would
think I was a celebrity and then people
would be like uh who's that
and then maybe follow me no I frankly
didn't think it was gonna work or if it
did work it was gonna be very brief and
I was like ready to do it finish it say
how did the two people it fell for it
and go back to work but no people
started taking pictures of me and I was
just walking really fast because I look
back at one point and I saw a lot of
people in Dutch it was terrifying I
didn't love it and then we stopped at
this corner to cross the street and then
they got all around me
[Music]
and the security-guard the actor was
really killing it I took like at least
like 40 pictures with strangers this
late it was like my daughter loves you
but she's so shy the girl was not trying
to take a picture with me I could tell
the mom wanted the picture there was
this couple like they were like my age
there was I Congrats on all your success
man we love your music it was like I can
tell and then this guy handed me his
mixtape and I was like no I cannot give
you any opportunities in a career Leeds
is a pig just like with the radio
interview I just went with it what they
said it's big news don't listen to it
they were asking me if I was beefing
with drape yeah yeah he followed me on
Twitter again so we're gonna go they
asked me again about Adam Lambert I am a
pathological liar and I loved it
Hollywood Ball December 13
as the Sun sets the crowd is still yet
to subside I felt overwhelmed
mostly when I was out with the crowd I
feel bad for celebrities that get
followed like that even though they are
not gonna do anything to you you just
don't feel safe having that many people
around you trying to touch you and push
you in whatever this is starting to feel
very uncomfortable so I was ready to go
and then you know our ride came and we
did so being famous for a day was very
tiring dude like I thought I was gonna
be really cool and it was but like you
go from one place to the other you have
people telling you what to do what's
your next spot and then you go meet fans
or whatever I don't think it's for me
I'm very tired right now I get very
anxious with all the people around me
the overall experience was cool I liked
it I don't regret it if I had to say if
I want to be famous I would say nope
Fame is dangerous it is invasive you
don't know how many walkers James I've
done in my life if I was being followed
like this oh man I don't wanna be famous
it's not for me but it was cool for a
day and with that so ends the tale of
how Fernando patron was famous for a day
we're trying to do some publicity for my
record that's dropping December 13 but
also some work for the orcas
the orcas are dying we need to get the
work estimate ation